[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
welcome back to whatever episode this is
of the joke world podcast a very special
hilarious guest today all the way out in
los angeles california he's been on the
joe rogan experience he has a new
special out right now he's done a ton of
other cool [ __ ] that we'll mention later
on we have fahim anwar hey thanks for
having me thank you for being here where
are you based out of you know where i am
yeah i'm in tampa right now tampa all
right that's a that's a comedy hot spot
you know you're in the thick of it dude
a lot of the greats come out of tampa
we got bert we got oh yeah
that's right yeah but it is a good spot
for uh like a ton of people come to do
side splitters and improv and they're in
like a range that they they can respond
to my dm if i can be like hey can i
interview with you while you're here so
this is a nice lawyer i jokingly say
that but i'm from seattle everyone kind
of like starts in a smaller city and
then comes the new yorker la so yeah i'm
sure there are a lot of great comedians
in tampa
was that always the plan to be like uh
you're in seattle is that always a plan
to end up in l.a or new york
kind of i think every comic reaches that
crossroads you know a couple years into
it where you're like okay do i go to new
york or l.a yeah it's funny like austin
is an option now whereas before that
wasn't um
so you go new york or la and then i grew
up in seattle my family's in seattle
it's a short plane ride to visit family
and i'm spending time as a kid yeah and
i don't have this
romance with new york or whatever it's
like it was like this foreign thing so
it's far away from my family and it's a
totally different way of life and i
wanted to be in tv and stuff and i'm
like uh la just made more sense do you
think that now with how people can blow
up just based on clips from like in
their home club like if you have a stage
that you get consistent time on and you
can have funny enough material and then
do a podcast maybe by yourself or
through zoom or something it's almost
like do you need to even be if you have
no interest in show business
do you even need to be in one of these
bigger cities now
less and less so i mean look at all
these famous um
like tick tockers and instagramers a lot
of times they'll gain so much traction
with their videos and then they're like
well i guess i gotta move to la now
they're just like all these
opportunities but it's not like they had
to pack up a suitcase with twine on the
top of their geo metro and drive to the
big city that's like a relic of
pre-internet so that's less important
these days it's like you make it exactly
what you said you make it and then you
go which might be a better
maybe a safer system less people go end
up homeless or totally you're not up
ending your life and and like
there are so many it's so cheap to be
creative and reach people nowadays um
yeah i'm just the
i'm a product of when i was born and
what the blueprint was for doing what
i'm doing and it's changed since i've
been in the comedy game like i've been
doing it 20 years and when i started
it was like okay you do a late night set
you do a half hour on comedy central and
like all the funny movies and tv shows
they draw from
you doing or you get on a sitcom and
you're like the wacky neighbor or some
[ __ ] who has like five lines and then
people come see your stand-up because
they know you from the tgif friday
whatever yeah but that's like not a
thing anymore i i don't think anyone
would even want to do that like cutting
up all these ones i think i might have
watched
more podcast footage than anyone in the
world on accident just cutting up all
these clips you know making these videos
and it's like the common theme that
people talk about is like they don't
it seems like comedians don't even
they're not striving for that anymore no
one's trying to be like i need to get
seinfeld or i need to get
yes it's refreshing you know because
that was the only way to get on because
there was like a certain number of
channels and that was the only way to
like reach people like reach people
through their living rooms is being the
wacky neighbor or something but what's
great about youtube podcasts and like
people can be so specific with their
tastes doing a podcast and doing
stand-up is enough to like
be to make a living doing standard like
you don't have to get on the sitcom for
people to know who you are like
fans of mine will watch this and like
we're just on two laptops you know it's
so bare bones it's crazy yeah and it's
like you don't even a step farther if
you can just carry a nice conversation
and you have enough experience there's
people that are just podcasters like a
lot of the barstool people that they're
in like the comedy world but they're
they're just podcasters you know they're
not even doing stand-up which is i guess
definite different than being a comedian
but there's like versions of it now
totally and and you get to do what you
do best instead of all right i'm a funny
stand-up let me try to say some funny
[ __ ] on a living room set
for this yeah
that's not your genius zone you know
your genius zone is stand up and like
podcasting and like nowadays that is
enough that's so true and then you could
turn into like like you hear i heard you
used to hear stories about like people
would come out to see bob saget thinking
that's the family or the full house guy
and then yeah what is this what is this
act i'm horrified well rogan would talk
about that too he would say
uh because when he was big off of fear
factor he would do tours and then
rogan just does his stuff and there's
some people who who like had an idea of
what the fear factor hosts comedy would
be like and they're walking out yeah
that's so ridiculous to think like what
i don't know what your assumption could
be based on the fear factor host
calories
that's what i was saying like what's
your expectations yeah i wanted more
from the guy who made people eat roaches
yeah i thought there'd be more puke in
this dude the funny thing watching those
back because after i heard enough of his
podcast episodes talking about it where
he would be like
you know i was so high for half of these
and then you go back and watch and it's
so funny just to watch him
not be joe rogan like fame how he is now
and just be like that is the highest
person in the world just like yeah and
making these people watch it again with
fresh eyes yeah so speaking of joe and
los angeles you're you're uh stand up
special out now the hat trick um or hat
trick is it the hat trick or hat trick
i think i just call it hat trick okay
yeah same thing like almost sure sure uh
is one of the most creative
specials or like pieces of content
um in my opinion it's at the legendary
comedy store one of the most if not the
famous clubs ever and it's in every
single room and it's one of those ideas
where it's like no one has thought of it
to do it at the store like that but then
once you once i heard about it i was
like oh that almost seems so obvious
that it's a great idea
bro i agree it's so bonkers like i still
can't believe
even when i thought of it i'm like has
anybody done this it's it's almost one
of those ideas that's in front of
everyone's noses and just i can't
believe no one had ever executed it
before so
especially
like for what i was trying to do
like at a point in my career where
yeah i've been in it for a long time and
i think a lot of comics know me and
stuff but like trying to bridge that gap
between
where i am as a stand-up comedian and
awareness it was like the perfect way
and device to do what i needed to do to
kind of make a splash because if i did
it at a like a theater like i did my
first cso one or whatever like that's
like a traditional stand-up special just
at a kind of faceless theater
like who who gives a [ __ ] there's a
million of those right so you can kind
of lean on the comedy store brand and
then so if someone that doesn't know who
you might necessarily be but knows the
store then yes you know they can come
yeah i'm drafting i'm drafting off of
the store
and
not in a sleazy way it's like i'm a paid
regular at the comedy store and that's
not nothing like that's a hard thing to
do and
also it's a magical place even when you
watch the special just like
i'm bringing theo up you know i'm
bringing marin up jaisal nick is
bringing me up and yeah i think
sometimes people forget how that's just
sort of like
a train station for a lot of comedians
when they're on the road they come
they're here
tuesday through thursday before they go
back on the road and just
juggernauts on this lineup and you're
like oh they're all just hanging out
talking between their sets yeah
i have so many questions about the store
and i want to keep going into them as i
hear you show another thing i'm like oh
that that that but i want to make sure i
get them all out so one of the things is
like that you kind of mentioned
about being a paid regular you're at
this it's like i don't i would assume
that they're not just letting anyone
film a three-room special in this club
and you even being a paid regular even i
feel like you got to carry some weight
to be like hey i want to i want to film
my special here yeah yeah so
i mean i'm fortunate that the store is
like
they're fans of mine and i've been i
think i was passed in 2010.
wow it's funny at the end of the special
i actually have footage of my name being
written on the wall that's from 2011 but
they saved it so it's like a year later
they actually painted it but i got
passed in 2010
so i've been there for a minute and i've
built those relationships and it's like
family there
um and when i had the idea i called up
peter shore because i knew i needed to
get their buy-in to do this
so i go this is the idea that i want to
do
i want to do it for youtube um
and this is like a genuine i honestly
wanted to do it for youtube it's not
like i tried to sell it in something
yeah and then i didn't get it sold i'm
like i want to do it
i'm just at a point where like i need
eyeballs right so i didn't want to sell
it to like a comedy central and like
nobody sees it yeah i've already i
already did that for my cecil one like
nobody even knows what the [ __ ] siso is
i don't know what see saul
you're you're into comedy
yeah yeah so nobody saw that one i
didn't want this to be in comedy jail i
just i'm doing okay money wise i just
wanted to get it i just need eyeballs at
this point in my career yeah and it's
also like not even
i mean it almost sounds like you're
talking about like youtube as like i
didn't want to sell it to these it's
almost like well youtube might be the
number one option anyway
like it is yeah i think it's it's turned
into that i think uh certain platforms
go through
um it goes through waves as to what the
hot platform is for stand-up comedy when
i was coming up well i think early early
days it was like hbo right because there
was like super rare specials and then
comedy central special was huge for a
while and then netflix has had her run
yeah and netflix still is something but
i think it's on the downturns just so
saturated um and youtube is is an
exciting place now with like normand and
these guys forged this new like schultz
yeah norman
yeah gillis
yeah yes davey it's exciting now and
like giannis yeah and i think it's
there's this whole brand of comedy where
the like people are watching these
specials be like well these are [ __ ]
great yeah this is better than a lot of
stuff that i'm being force-fed via
netflix
and you know comedy central
oh they sort of have they're almost
casting like those whatever i have
meetings with those like this they're
nice people and all that but when you
are part of uh some conglomerates and
media conglomerate
your taste can get very narrow but
anyone can upload to youtube and that's
the beauty like you can get someone like
savvy you can get somebody like giannis
and yeah i think the response is showing
people that there's an appetite for that
and they're the every special is like
multi-millions like it doesn't seem like
many of these are missing
and or if they are missing they still
end up very popular and also the other
thing about youtube is like the comments
you don't have netflix comments but
people are like
like forming like giving you a
compliment in the comments so then that
has a thousand likes and it's like you
can build fans and the fans can build
like camaraderie with each other like
hey we're both fans of the same guy and
we're like talking about him in the ca
you don't get that unless it's youtube
yeah that's a good point there is a sort
of built-in community with comments and
the ease of a hyperlink and forums and
stuff
that's something that that's a secondary
thing that i've come to know by putting
it out on youtube i just wanted to reach
people right but i'm noticing the effect
of people donating money and and like
just sort of vibing in the comment
section and having a huge special on
your youtube channel versus putting it
on even like there's other you like
youtube channels that feature
other specials and have a bunch of
specials but putting it on your own
then you get all the subscribers from
this popping off not some other company
so then you're building up your youtube
for if you want to put podcast clips on
there if you want to put you know and
you don't get that from netflix like
netflix isn't like like they're getting
more subscribers and then you're just
still hoping that they look you up on in
their own time on their own phone like
it's nice to do that too i think youtube
is
has to be the most like the number one
option i'd say yeah and i think the
algorithm behooves the comedian as well
because when i do another podcast or
something uh this special will be in the
sidebar it'll get recommended it kind of
knows the taste of the user whereas with
netflix you have a one week window like
a one yeah for it to kind of catch and
if it doesn't you're buried yeah no one
is going to discover your [ __ ] yeah
there's so many specials like the comedy
section you can even in the stand-ups
you can press and they keep going and
going and going and i'm like
first of all like i'm into comedy i
haven't heard of some of these people
and they keep going back and back and
back and then you're also dealing with
ozark and a bunch of other like [ __ ]
like
there's so much [ __ ] on there it's like
i can't compete with ozark
so so you're filming this special you
knew it was for youtube the whole time
is the process is a creative process all
in your hands is there anyone that was
like helping you uh shoot and direct or
like any um well obviously like you
weren't filming while you were on stage
but it kind of was a little bit not with
the filming but with audio so i'll tell
you the genesis of what happened so
i knew that i wanted to do this idea
like all three rooms the comedy store
and i was actually going to have my
buddy aristotle direct it but then he
got snl
all right so he got a little busy he
wasn't able to do it what if he was like
i can't do it i got to direct my buddies
he directed my first special um
that there's no business like show
business that one's on youtube as well
but he directed that
so i mean he's a great he's just a like
all-around really talented guy in
everything so i wanted him to direct
this one again but he he got snl and he
wasn't able to
and then he hooked me up with um
this other uh like dp director that he
knows
and i met with him really nice guy i
told him what i wanted to do
and we cased the comedy store and he was
sort of a little more
professional he wanted to like rent
cameras he wanted to like hire crew and
and then and this is him doing like a
bare bones budget for what he wanted to
do and it he like clocked it it was
gonna be like 40k or 50k and i was only
gonna have three nights to like get it
okay
and that just sort of seemed like that's
not what i'm trying
to do with this that's too much money it
just seemed like overkill right like
that was lean in his mind but it felt
bloated to me right right
footprint wise and financially i'm like
this doesn't feel like
what i need to accomplish it so
after hemming and hawing i was like ah
thank you but i think i'm going in a
different direction and then i just
ended up helming it like i knew what i
needed like i directed the special so
the comedy store had two cameras already
these black magics
and then there was another guy who
worked on jonathan vogler who helped me
out a little bit just with coordinating
and
he knew the is it the canon c 200 or 300
so at for a floater so i mean it was
pretty bare bones it was two cameras on
monopods and then one floater
and i kind of knew
the dynamic shots that i wanted and
and then audio wise like i i'm a little
techy as well so i knew how to get the
stuff so it was sort of one man banding
it just
logging a few sets
um that was awesome and just knowing
knowing the look and feel that i wanted
uh i really had it in my head and it was
just sort of
playing quarterback yeah and i'm so i'm
so glad that the series of events
happened the way it did
because
i don't know if i would have taken the
reigns like i did
because i had to right that makes sense
and that's like the whole beauty of
doing it on youtube or in this new like
renaissance of comedians just being
their own basically every comedians like
their own company at this point of just
like content and stuff is that you could
just do it exactly how you picture it in
your head and then that's like how it
comes out and you don't have to ask
anyone to do anything yeah i hope that
it kind of ushers in this new era of
because the overhead is so much lower um
just i you know how there's a tech
bubble and and there's all these things
that just i think stand-up got so
bloated and fat and overproduced
and just unnecessarily it's like we're a
guy or a girl with a [ __ ] microphone
on a stage why is there a dunkirk avatar
budget like
it makes no sense all the work has been
done with like in the clubs and working
these jokes out yeah you're just sharing
ideas why is there [ __ ] lasers and
[ __ ] like so true it really just takes
away from it if anything and it
and like when it's that bloated
these companies don't want to give the
comedian any control because they're
trying to protect their budget so you
can't if you have something that's a
little off-kilter or different than
what's been done
these companies don't want to like pay
that much money to have you do it yeah
so
you'll there's all these cookie cutter
type
specials that that look the same and
feel the same whereas now with youtube
and consumer grade
cameras and all and audio equipment i
think comedians can really
take oh not say hey just here it is film
it like you can kind of be in the weeds
right and be like i want it to be this
way and
you can do something different and more
like hat trick is very me um somebody
else
has a different style and they can make
a special that's very them it doesn't
have to be the comedy central half hour
here's a toy crane to drop the comedian
in yeah
let's bring in the other comedian and
it's just the led where the name changes
yeah they probably filmed it with the
same crowd like totally they're watching
their fifth comedian it's like so tired
it's like some family from ohio like
[ __ ]
okay can we leave yeah like i just had a
jersey mic sandwich i want to leave no
you have to stay until they're all done
yeah and you have to
that's um that's one thing that i think
i've heard you say before too is you
want it to be like a fly in the wall
experience at the store so
for hat trick so like if there was a
crane with a camera on it coming in like
swooping down and everyone so were the
people in aware that there was a special
being filmed no they had no idea so
again that's kind of
why i think the special special's a
little different than the one i did
before and just other ones and the feel
that i wanted to create it was a regular
night of operation and that's what i
told peter shore when i had the idea i
go i don't need to rent out any rooms or
anything i'm just
i'm barely there it's such a small
footprint people won't even know
anything is being taped the cameras are
in the back they're super small yeah
there might be a floater but he's like
yeah people would have no idea because
it's just like
um really small operation and it since
it's a regular night of operation
there's i forget how many comics are on
a lineup maybe 10 or 8
so
there's different they're not there for
me
i may be like i may be a good comedian
but
i don't think awareness-wise half the
room is there for me or something i'm
still kind of an unknown like if you're
a comedy fan you kind of know who i am
but those people
the sets that i did at the comedy store
most of the people don't know who i am
so i think that's kind of cool yeah that
you are watching
a special where
it's um you're making strangers laugh
right and
so much of stand-up is that
i know we see the gloss of like you know
bert and like burr and these are you
know great comedian and stuff um or like
norman and lis and like louis ck and
shane
like they have their audience when
somebody watches
joe coy or something it's like he has
it's it's a party you know or bert it's
a party
but it's a different thing where
they're like who is this guy that's so
true i think capturing that is kind of
cool i've never thought about that angle
before but it's like every
special
that we've probably ever all watched is
a crowd full of people that are like die
hard maybe not die hard but like fans of
the person that they're there for they
probably know that it's a taping and you
know you see the specials where like the
first joke is like
people are falling out of their chairs
or screaming because they know that it's
a special and they know that this is
like they're trying to make it go well
but that is that the purest form of
comedy probably what you did would be
how comedy how stand-up is and closer
yes closer to it and also um people
inherently change when there is a camera
in the room
so if you see
so if you see like a crane or something
people i mean they'll still enjoy the
show but i just feel like it changes the
energy yeah
that's not to say i won't do another
special where there's cameras in a
traditional way but i think there's
something cool about
capturing a stand-up show where no one
knows it's being filmed it feels like a
more
realistic feel and authentic thing of
what happens at a comedy club so did the
other comics on the lineup know that you
were doing this no not really because it
was so i mean they would in the hallway
if they saw that night that i happened
to have like the guy but again it wasn't
like there's a grip and a roadie with a
walkie and [ __ ] yeah it just might be
like a guy or two with a small camera
were you ever nervous and then they'll
oh yeah were you ever nervous that like
since no one in the in the building
really knew that like something
something crazy could happen or like
were you would crowdwork have made it
into your uh special if someone was like
you know doing something that had to be
addressed or something went awry in the
in the audience uh no like that's i mean
part of doing it this way was just
having that
um
safety net and buffer of you're able
just to log a few sets
so again i was trying to remove the
preciousness of a special because even
when you do a theater type special
it is this sort of the comedians on a
balance beam there's there's lit there's
lights there's fog the audience is there
and you're watching
it's like it's the social contract where
everyone's all right let's stick the
landing for this special yeah yeah
whereas
doing it this way the overhead was so
low and we already had the cameras we
were able to log
a few sets right so so it's not like
oh this has got to be it
it's not like oh there's two hundred
thousand dollars on this show tonight
i've gotta get it yeah cause that's not
that's not a recipe for good comedy
either right just pressure high pressure
cooker situation
is not
that's why even like montreal and stuff
i mean
it is montreal time right now but i kind
of wanted to do a tweet just be like you
know uh
like oh what is it good luck to all the
comedy execs who go and watch their one
stand-up show for the year and base all
their decisions for the network for the
next five that's crazy that that is
it's just
[ __ ] system that exists in
traditional hollywood comedy you have
these like suits
who
if they were smart they would just call
comedy clubs up and not just it doesn't
have to be the store it could be the
improv it can be hyper lyric hyperion it
can be all these different scenes and be
like who's good yeah who do you like
who's making waves yeah but instead they
go to french canada
once a year
to watch an american comedian do their
set
like some 23 year old kid and who's like
nervous as [ __ ] and they've heard the
the lore of new faces you see them do
six minutes well they're trying not to
pee their pants in front of people on
their iphones that's crazy and they're
gonna base their the entirety of their
comedic being off of their one
performance and if they do kind of
whatever
oh i've seen him they'll say that for
the next six to eight years it's like a
broken system that's insane and then
that person can pop off on tick tock and
they'll and have a way better career you
don't even need to do that [ __ ] i almost
feel like like you know if it works out
for for someone that route that's
awesome that's fantastic
but
you have tick tock you have there's so
many other ways to do it yeah if if we
were in the 90s all right that's the
game that's what you got to play but
there's so many other ways to do it yeah
you don't need to subscribe to that
that's crazy that you that you say that
because i remember watching like that
there's a documentary and it was like
rosebud baker she's the only person i
can remember that was in it but it was
about a class of new faces and they were
like
it was some people that didn't make it
it was the people like scouting and
going to the different bar shows around
and like figuring out who it was and
then like basically the process of
montreal i remember watching that like
all right this is this is the only way
to get into comedy i guess is like you
gotta figure out how to do this and then
i i remember i looked up like right
after i watched that documentary when
the next uh new faces was and it was
like i missed it by like a month so it
was like in 11 months and i was like oh
[ __ ] and then i don't think i ever
remember that again yeah
that's
it's whatever it's still a thing it's
sort of like summer camp for a lot of
industry people they get to go to french
canada
unwind hang out drink see some comedy
but as an artist it's frustrating where
you're like
this is your one data point for
every two years
but then do you think that they see
people
like
like you or like these people that are
just
not doing that route and having so much
success do you think that anyone in the
industry is like looking over their
shoulder like dude we might be running
out of time having a grip on this thing
or you think they're just drinking their
own kool-aid so much they don't even
know that there's this whole thing going
on i think they drink their kool-aid for
as long as they can before it kind of
creeps up on them like
uh like comedy central for the longest
time they they were just sort of they
were not embracing digital forever right
just like they were they were [ __ ]
with their own player for the longest
time they weren't embracing youtube yeah
they were trying to get this comedy
central player to work for their stuff
they had this huge library of half hours
and then netflix just
was pushing the envelope of digital and
and just comedy central was too late
yeah they thought they were gonna be on
top forever so that's what happens it's
hollywood will have their way of doing
it and then
um tick tock and all these people will
pop off and then they'll throw money at
it
they'll still be okay because they have
like endless supply of money and they
can but they're just a little late to
adopting whatever the newest trend is
yeah that makes sense all right so going
back to some of the comedy store
questions because i've been just
obsessed with the
the comedy store growing up because i'm
i'm a rogan fan growing up and i feel
like there was a time where he plugged
the store every podcast episode for like
years and years would just be talking
about these great stories and great
memories there and some not so great
memories that he had there but i've just
known about this place and i've i've
never been there yet it's one of my
all-time
goals or you know bucket list items to
go see some
uh you know the the close experience
i've had is being the fly on the wall
watching you're special actually which
is pretty nice but were you aware when
you from went from seattle to los
angeles were you aware of the lore of
the comedy store already
well what's interesting is when i got
there
the lore wasn't what it is now it was
sort of
running on fumes from the past lore with
like eddie murphy because it was dead
when i got there
um it wasn't dead like bobby lee talks
about in the 90s um that was like a
different type of dead but it was still
not a popular
venue okay um a lot of it wouldn't be
sold out a lot of nights it was all
about meltdown when i was when i got
past the store so it wasn't a cool
place to see comedy um
meltdown with kumail and jonah ray
that was like the hot show the alt scene
was really big like ucb
comedy death ray
um i think crash crash test with rob
hubel
the improv was pretty popping as well
but no one was coming by
and it was sort of nice as a stand-up
just to have that like nothing mattered
you can take huge risks and swings and
as a comedian know that
um some suit isn't gonna be in the crowd
like
you could just artistically thrive
because nothing mattered
and then
it started to pick up especially because
rogan didn't come by the store i think
after the mencia fallout he just
because i think uh
i mean i may be
thinking of it wrong or whatever this is
just my understanding i think they kind
of went with mencia because he was
making the most money at the time yeah
that's what i've put together is he had
that like banned for some some time and
yeah so that was annoying he came back
to see he says he came back the first
time to see ari
special yeah because he had his which
was the first ever one to be filmed
there
yeah paid regular yeah uh well no there
was like richard pryor live at the
soccer strip that was the main room um
so
he would only play i remember when i was
passing the store he wasn't coming by
and he would just play the ice house
in pasadena so that was where he would
do most of his stand up
he would never come by the store and
then
yeah ari shafir was taping his uh
special paid regular for comedy central
and and
you know they're such boys and ari
opened up for rogan so much and he's
like i have to be there for for this
and then when he came back
i think the energy in the juju which he
which was off-putting to him at the time
with the mencia stuff like enough time
had passed yeah where there was new
people new energy and
like he really [ __ ] with it and he
started coming back more and more and
then when he came back and then his
podcast kept i mean his pocket was
always big but it's just been on an
exponential
rise um now it's like a world now it's
like yeah totally every day i wake up i
go on twitter it just says joe rogan
trending on it's so funny well is that
crazy going
on like onto that show like i can't even
i don't don't understand how people
aren't so nervous that they can't even
talk when they're on that show like uh i
guess because it's it's uh it doesn't
feel like like when you do a late night
or something it is that [ __ ] out of a
cartoon where there's curtains you open
up the curtains there's lights there's
cameras there's guy with a headset
there's seth
meyers right there so there is
those hallmark pings like
like dream stuff that you have just like
high pressure [ __ ] um
but with rogan you just you go
i i know him from from the comedy story
not it's not this foreign yeah
this foreign thing i've already talked
to him i know him he's a friend you know
and then also you're just hey do you
want to water blah blah blah you're
sitting at the conference it's like i'm
talking to you right now yeah
so
yeah it gets beamed into a bunch of [ __ ]
but in the moment it feels like this
that makes sense there's not
30 million listeners in the room with
you just like yes there's not some
family from the midwest on bleachers and
a fanny pack looking at you while we're
doing this
you know there's not a warm-up guy
between you and i talking about
hat-trick
that makes a lot of sense there was that
time that you know before
kovid before a lot of people started
leaving la where following the comedy
store on instagram you'd see them post
the lineup and you'd be like how is this
ticket not like 500 dollars like it's
like joe rogan theovan crystal it's like
crazy crazy lineups
was that like
bizarre to be a part of was it have you
noticed a difference since then like is
that
coming back on in a way yeah the shows
are still
pretty great they're all sold out still
like it's uh
i was wondering what it was going to be
like post pandemic and especially some
people
left town
but theo will still come in like it's
still great like ali wong was there the
other night and like uh burr popped in
so it still has
it still has crazy lineups it may not be
as insane as
before covet or whatever especially
because like joe's gone and
some people aren't there anymore but
yeah yeah
but there's they're still pretty insane
lineups i will say you don't know what
it is until
like you don't know you're in this kind
of renaissance and heyday until you're
on the other side of it
but i having some perspective on it it
was pretty nuts just any night of the
week it'll be like burr sebastian
segura rogan
and then and then me so what's
interesting is like
i'm on those lineups just like nobody
it's bizarre because you may be
a good comedian
but when nobody knows who you are
um it's
it's it's a different thing like then
you have joey diaz as well because these
guys are like great comedians and people
know who they are
so then it was fun and i enjoyed those
times and everything but i have noticed
a little difference where
now i feel like
because it is not so star heavy like
there still are but it's not the [ __ ]
insanity that it was right
i feel like um
like me and some other communities are
able to kind of our signal is able to
reach audiences a little
more that makes sense because it because
the gravitational pull of rogan is like
so big or like
or like burr or people who were so when
it was that stacked
even if you're a funny comedian
if you're unknown
it's hard to cut through that noise yeah
and i found like in this new era it's
been
a little easier for me to cut through
the noise yeah and it's not even like
like we're saying like known but people
like bill burr and joe and theo and joey
diaz these are people that like
fans know but there's people that are
obsessed with them like not even like
just regular fans they have like super
super like crazy fans that almost like
they could go to the store see those
guys and then still be you know in awe
that they just saw joey diaz while
you're on stage all they're thinking
about
is enjoying this
exactly so it's like and we're like two
different frequencies like i love joey
but like
we're we're like different if you're in
it's like metallica's a great band and
then so is michael jackson yeah there's
not a ton of crossover yeah and
sometimes that happens with comedy where
if you have an act that is a certain
type of frequency that 80 of the crowd
is there for
even though you have your own thing and
merit it's going to be hard to kind of
like get into the hearts of yeah that
other 80 percent i'd say joey diaz does
not have a lot of frequency similarities
with anyone
like that i think he cuts through a lot
of frequencies though i think no matter
who you are it's just like a whirlwind
yeah
is there anyone that you'd be like
because you're peers with all these
people were was there any times that
you'd be you know in the back and just
be like oh my god so and so is here or
like pass someone in the hallway and be
like oh my god you know uh
so cr chris rock was there i mean i've
seen him come through the or
several times but
i'm at a point in my career now where
i'm in the meat of the lineup just i
think in the past i would be so far
where our paths wouldn't even really
cross
but
i'm like one of the guys now so
like i bring him
on stage and like we see each other now
so i think this moment happened where
i didn't
i didn't know he that's the thing about
the comedy store it's so dark you don't
know who's there or so i'm just doing my
set
and then i get a piece of paper so
that's usually when there's a drop in or
something because you you know who
you're going to bring up
so
i get the piece of paper and says you
know chris rock so i'm like
oh my god this is like you know what a
trump drop in give some great intro you
know yeah like ladies and gentlemen
chris rock
and then he comes up and he's like oh
that was funny man and then
and then i hear from multiple people
they're like yo he was dying during your
set uh
so in like multiple comics it was like
yeah he was in the buckets he's just
like dying
and that was just such a
milestone and moment for me um like
bigger than any audition that i like
booked or
hollywood [ __ ] just feels like i'm
visiting
that that meant so much because he's
mount rushmore he's one of the comedy
greats i can take that to the grave with
me like
people can say whatever like you have
trolls and trolls and [ __ ] but i can be
like
nah you're wrong
like yeah cause i have such a north star
yeah with this like i was pretty good
even without having that like i'm i'm
compartmentalized and i like i can
mentally handle that [ __ ] it's fine but
just knowing
like six different people are telling me
like chris rock was dying in the bucket
seats
i'm golden i'm gravy that's that's so
that's such a cool part about comedy and
so interesting to hear because it's like
you have probably you know with views
everything total in person online you've
probably made millions of people laugh
but just this one guy that you made
laugh is like
the the peak of well
yeah because he is in the field and the
industry that i care so much about like
he is a purist like me
um he is
he has discerning taste yeah like those
are i feel like
chris rock
seinfeld like even like neil brennan
like very they don't give it up so when
they when they do that that means a lot
i haven't gotten kudos from seinfeld
though so but but neil and i haven't
really met seinfeld so
that would be amazing for me as well
like i you know i love him too have you
do did you have a favorite comedian
growing up
uh
who did i like you know what's weird is
i didn't grow up um watching stand-up i
wasn't
uh it wasn't till i was like 17 that i
it kind of get on my i got on my radar
um i grew up with the simpsons conan and
snl okay that that sort of my comedy dna
as a child like my teachers
and then i saw delirious so eddie murphy
delirious okay and then i was like oh
what is this yeah
yeah so you mentioned snl that reminds
me you do some sketch stuff too or you
did um
is that then like obviously goat face
and then some other just random
funny sketches with people and and teams
and stuff is that do you like doing that
compared to being on stage like are
those laughs different to you like you
know you put out a really funny sketch
with other people versus doing it by
yourself do you have a preference or is
it all just comedy i'm just a fan of
ideas
and like comedic ideas
and
uh whatever the right bucket for that
idea kind of wins so
i'm never like i want to get a laugh of
us off of a sketch or i want to get a
laugh off a stand-up it's just sort of
like what's the idea i have
and is this what's the best delivery
system for the idea right is it a tweet
is it a sketch
is it like a stripped-down ig sketch is
it a fully produced boom mic get a
camera guy sketch
um
that's interesting so yeah that's that's
how i approach it i love both yeah um
i'm just i'm just all about like what's
the best way to service this this idea
yeah that makes a ton of sense
it so you you know the writing process
for you is that let's just do just stand
up now because you can come up with
these ideas and then
figure out where what should best
represent them but just for stand-up are
you
um pen to paper did you start off you
know trying to write a different way and
has that evolved are you someone that is
taking a topic on stage with nothing
no like set memorization on and just
working out up there what does that kind
of look like for you uh
i'm at a point now i just i jot it down
on my phone because my phone's on me all
the time i don't have to worry about
having a pen and paper i always have my
phone
and then i have i use evernote that that
app some people use notes on ios just
something that is synced between my
phone and my laptop
so that if i update one it'll update on
the other
i find that beneficial that
whatever i think of if i'm at a chipotle
or something it'll be there when i flesh
it out a little more on my laptop or
vice versa
so i'm at a point where i don't really
like sit down
and set x number of minutes or hours to
writing
not that that's wrong or anything some
people do do that i think seinfeld does
that he kind of i think an hour a day or
something he does that i just sort of
live life and
i'm good at recognizing the novel idea
and then jotting down enough words to
capture the thought yeah so i don't
write out the entire bit maybe it'll be
a phrase or a sentence if it's important
that i'll put that in there but it's
almost like a stenographer
so as few words as possible
to capture the different
branches of the uh
the bit or right whatever it is so just
jot down don't lose the idea yeah yeah
the biggest the biggest thing is
what was that thing or right
uh [ __ ] like losing a great idea sucks i
hate that feeling yeah or when you think
that you're just going to remember it
and then you don't
yeah i love that mitch hedberg has this
great joke i may be butchering it he
goes like you know i'm a stand-up
comedian so when i think about something
funny i have to like find a pen
and if the pen's too far away i have to
convince myself what i thought of wasn't
that funny
yeah that's hilarious it's so true so
lazy so i'll jot it down on my phone
um
or if i'm in a pinch or something i'll
just do a voice recorder on my watch oh
or phone and just say say you know what
the idea is
and so i have that in a in a folder it's
called like new bits
and that just keeps on getting pushed
down while i have new ones and then when
i do sets around town i have set lists
just sort of
what i'm trying to do for that set okay
and then when i do a different set then
i'll maybe like cut this one out and
yeah so it's always
there's different modifications there's
like new bits and then there's different
set lists that makes sense what was that
process like
after you release a special either the
last time or the time before that
building it up from
from nothing yeah scratch
it's some people hate that they may seem
daunting and like i've got nothing and
there is an element of that but i find
it so
invigorating and
uh
because it's hard to keep
i think of a lot of stuff all the time
there's all these ideas bouncing around
and then yeah when you're when you're
trying to put a special together you
have to keep you have to be pretty tight
and have these bits and the flow of
these bits and it's mental energy for me
at least
just
okay i've got to keep that tight it's a
lot of mental disk space that i've gotta
that's taken up with all these ideas and
to keep it until you get on wax right
then it's done
it's this great purge oh i can [ __ ]
forget about all those ideas and i can
start a new is it easy
if you're not it's like going to the gym
if
if i'm gearing up for this hour or
something and then i don't do stand-up
for two weeks or three weeks or i do it
or i start working on a different type
of set
it's gonna [ __ ] up with my
from just the way i operate
i like to kind of have it locked in a
bit before i do something important
right i i don't want to
do all these different types of sets in
different order before i film something
because i'm going to my brain is going
to be like
what what's the order
what goes after what that makes sense i
like to lock it in mentally yeah but
when i'm not taping something i do that
all the time i like to just
because that's how you find the nice
flow and order of something so do you
mostly work stuff out at the store and
around los angeles or will you you know
take risks on the road is that different
to have
fans you know people that are like
just kid like
paying is does the ticket price change
your um material at all like oh i really
have to deliver if
they paid x amount or if it's totally
yeah totally for me um
yeah so i kind of
i feel out whatever the show is uh or i
just have this mental
um
i don't know this like gradient of what
to do on what show even within the
comedy store if it's a tuesday night in
the original room and i'm on kind of
later
i'll i'll throw some new stuff in there
i'll have my phone on the stool
um it's not going to be a complete like
all new ideas but i'll work in a few new
bits it's a little less precious than
the o.r the main room
is such it's a bigger room
uh it's more cavernous there's less
momentum it's less jazzy like the or you
can get a rolling laugh people can pick
up on really fine details but the main
room is so like las vegas here it is
it just sort of screams polish
yeah where if you're a bigger comedian
maybe you can
like if chris rock goes in there sarah
silverman they can read from a pad
because everyone's just so excited yeah
this celebrity is there but when when
you're like who is this guy why is he on
his phone in this big room it feels
weird so i won't do a lot of new stuff
in the main room yeah
and also when i do the road if i'm
headlining
people are paying pretty good money to
come see me
so i'm not gonna be like workshopping a
ton
on those shows and if i do i've done
this before where
i think i did at the brea improv i i did
my time and then at the end just as a
free spin i'm like can i work on some
stuff you guys cool because like they
already got the show right right so this
is just on top this is the cherry on top
yeah no one's gonna feel wronged right
if anything they might feel like they're
like behind the scenes or like in your
pocket of being like oh we're going to
help you out like we're on your team you
know and then if something goes bad it's
almost funnier than if it went well if
they know what's going on
yeah and comedy people are so savvy
nowadays like even with like your
channel and the stuff you're putting out
people like the behind the scenes and
how the sausage gets made whereas back
in the day
people only knew stand-ups through their
like carson appearances they only knew
them through their polished art yeah but
now
with us on podcasts with us talking
about our process and [ __ ] people if
you're a fan of stand-up you can really
drill down on the details and that's fun
for
like the rabid comedy yeah so like a lot
of people love that i did that at the
bream bro they're like oh [ __ ] i love
those new bits or like that was fun yeah
it was like they got deleted scenes or
something and it's going to be even
cooler for them if you were in one of
those shows and then it ends up on a
public platform like on a polished
special to be like i saw that when it
was being built from scratch and i think
a lot of like maybe back in the day
people
didn't know that
this is something that interests the
fans is like the technical nerdy maybe
do you think it's boring but a lot of
people are super interested in this
maybe that i feel like there was almost
like a curtain that they didn't want to
people to see behind or didn't know that
people even wanted to see behind i think
it's that i think people
uh
i i wouldn't have known when i first
started out that people would want to
know the nitty-gritty kind of day-to-day
nuts and bolts of stand-up you think
that they just want the polished part of
it but
um people are interested in like the
demystification of stand-up yeah yeah
because
it is
it's like this magic power that you look
at the person on stage is making you
just make these noises against your will
and it's like how and they're so
confident up there and they're not
nervous and they're public speaking and
they're so funny everything is working
perfectly you're like how is this even
possible and it's like well
not everyone can do it but these are
some some of the steps that
yeah it's like seeing a car on the road
and being like what the [ __ ] yeah and
then you open up the hood and you go oh
i mean not that you know gears and [ __ ]
but like yeah you go oh it's not just
some magic piece of metal moving through
exactly
there's actually some mechanics to this
that that is a great analogy that's that
makes a lot of sense yeah floating metal
well thank you so much for uh being able
to come on the show today we'll keep it
about 50 minutes or so i think this was
a
great conversation i had a good time
talking some comedy with you and uh do
you have any socials or upcoming dates
oh let's see
instagram fahim anwar twitter fahimanor
tiktok faheman or comedy my youtube
which is like i think the most important
especially with the special dropping on
there i'm trying to like build that out
and put more stand-up content that's
just youtube.com fahimanwar
um i'll be touring starting touring in
the fall i'll have some dates that'll
that'll go out from there
um
yeah so check out hat trick that was
filmed at the comedy store i'm really
proud of it and then the previous
special comedy central it's on their
youtube now so that one's called there's
no business like show business
and uh in terms of demystifying stand-up
and just like the how the sausage gets
made i'm starting to do this series
called
fahim works on stuff and his friends
drop by it's a monthly show that i do at
the comedy store
where
i emcee but i just do new material in
between all the acts and it's just like
literally diarying these ideas for the
first time yeah and it's a lot of fun
some of them work some of them don't but
it's you kind of get to see the baby
steps of stand-up and i think that's
kind of fun content for my fans as well
to see something other than just the
polished bits yeah it's literally all in
the name there too yeah
and i like the the title of the show
people know what it is it's like five
bucks it's super low-key and it's just
an exercise for me to get these ideas
out there so yeah when people buy
tickets that vaheem works on stuff and
it's filmed right by it that's how one
is gonna be mad yeah yeah yeah that's
layers all right that sounds dope we're
gonna link everything all the socials
and we'll get the specials um in the bio
of this video uh thank you so much again
for your time man great to meet you of
course dude yeah yeah i love your stuff
and uh keep trucking i'll be keeping an
eye out sweet thanks
i love these zooms when they end and
then we're like but then we're still
just staring at each other
[Music]
foreign